Speaker 1: Let's go to Dee
Baby from Is it al sace? I
don't know that I'm pronouncing
any of these things correctly.
Deb, are you there?
Speaker 3: Yes, it's all states,
can you can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Yes, it's always I'll say this.
Speaker 1: Where is all space?
Speaker 3: ISIS sits on the border of France.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK, beautiful.
What's on your mind, baby?
Speaker 3: Well, you know, I've just.
I've just been in a little little, little down
lately. Mm-Hmm. You know, it just. Just feels
like we keep we keep, you know, this this
inching, inching progress forward. You know,
it just feels like it's it's, you know,
one step forward, five steps back.
Half a step forward, eight steps back. I
don't know it, just it just seems like we
were going down, I don't know, do you do you
have any, any sort of sort of any sort of
feeling that we're, you know, that this
trend is going to change or we can give
Speaker 1: you some examples of the steps forward
and the steps back, so I would know what you mean.
Speaker 3: I mean, it just I I guess I
guess one way to think of it is, is sort of
if you look at what's happening
with inflation right now,
you know, like we just. All these.
Speaker 1: Deb, thank you. Appreciate the call.